[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time
i'm rhett and i'm linked this week at
the round table of dim lighting
we're talking about the surprising items
that
are revolutionizing our everyday lives
you know you might you might say man
that product sounds stupid
but until you find yourself or someone
close to you using it constantly
you're like man maybe there's something
to this well also i mean i think this is
something you thought you couldn't
you thought you could do without but now
you realize you you need it
you need it every day uh we got a lot of
responses
you said you asked the question you
didn't finish the sentence we said
what's the surprising item that
has revolutionized your everyday life
maybe it's a special tool a gadget
something around the house work school
you know just trying to jog people's
thoughts because
we put these prompts out there y'all if
you respond to them
it we're going to talk about we're going
to talk about your perspectives
and we do this uh we do this on twitter
twitter you know twitter
so at mythical follow us some people
have created twitter accounts just to
participate we appreciate that
that's nice we hear you we notice um
so we'll get to that in a second but
something has happened to me
two days in a row and i just want to
throw it out there and see if you
you think there's any significance to it
oh significance
uh okay this is not unusual i think that
lots of people talk about this
phenomenon but
it hasn't happened to me in a while and
it's happened
two days in a row okay
waking up and knowing
that i have woken up one minute before
my alarm
oh yes yeah yeah and not just
not just looking it's uncanny not just
looking over to
guess but having an
a knowledge and then looking over to
confirm it oh
um okay no that's it so you have a
knowledge
okay your eyes aren't even open yet but
you know you're you know you're waking
up and you're about to look at the clock
and you're saying
this my clock's gonna go off in one
minute well somebody know that my phone
is on a little
stand a wireless stand stan
it's not something i i i i can live
without it it's not an item that i'm
going to talk about
but it is a new thing that i got that
has my watch
my phone and my error but what do you
call them airpods
i don't know all wirelessly charging on
one thing
it's kind of cool but my phone
here's why i know that i'm not being
influenced by seeing it
i have to hit my phone in order to turn
the screen on to see what time it is
that's the only indication of what time
it is
so yesterday i woke up it's interesting
and i was like my alarm's about to go
off
it like literally it's going to go off
if i don't reach over there reach over
there with 6 29.
my alarm went off at 6 30. but i stopped
it literally like
15 seconds so i was like oh okay well
that happens
this morning yeah alarm is set for 6 15.
i don't get up at the same time every
day difference they had different things
going on
that's the weird thing oh two different
times okay that that kind of blows the
theory here right that's why i'm so
shaken about it crazy all right so today
was day two this morning
well i i got to get more data man okay i
woke up this morning
and i had the same feeling and i will
say just
in full disclosure it was 6 13.
so it wasn't 6 14. it wasn't one minute
but it was
two minutes and i was like and i was
like day
you would set it at the same time i did
it again here's the thing that's wow
this isn't
normal now it when i get up at the same
time but i don't get up at the same time
i don't i get up at the same time and
there's
many times when i wake up right before
the alarm goes off
and you also go to bed at the same time
right yeah if you go to bed at the same
time you get up at the same time this is
not unusual
but i haven't gone to bed at the same
time i was special too so
no because your body is adjust to a
rhythm no i'm special
you're special in other ways everyone
knows that
um but i don't go to bed at the same
time
every day yeah that's uh my my bedtime
range it's not a circadian
thing it is i mean sometimes i might be
like i'm really tired and i'll go to bed
at
9 30. like i'll go to bed at 9 30 and
then sometimes i'll be like
it's midnight i haven't thought about
bed yet i'll go to bed at 12 30. and
any of these things can happen it has
nothing to do no i just have whatever
happens happens
and then the morning is based on what i
need to do that day are you so
when you're going to bed do you make the
decision do you set your alarm clock
because that's changing too apparently
you make a decision will it be 6 15 will
it be 6
30 yeah and how big of a range
is that no earlier than 6 o'clock
no later than 7 30. and if i if if i
don't set my if
i need to if i want to sleep later i
can't sleep past 7 30. i cannot it's i
it is physically now that i've hit my
40s physically impossible to sleep past
7
30 and i really really hate that i can
go back to sleep but i do wake up
well listen i'm going to count the third
day this morning you got three days in a
row
um i think you need to keep track in
this because maybe there's some
this is something harnessed supernatural
no that's really with a question
i i wish it was going to be fun to talk
about do you think that it is
i can't say well do you think it's the
beginning of
maybe i could be maybe i'm like this is
my origin story
for like a superhero the guy who can
wake up
right before his alarm and harnesses
that as a super power the alarm
anticipator the weight yeah that's good
the anticipation
exactly i would that's this is what i'm
saying i will be called the anticipator
and i'll start anticipating things
right before they happen in saving
people well okay
like uh like dismantling a bomb nope
it's things that it has to be things
that are based on a schedule like you're
taking
rain is coming if you were taking a nap
and there was a bomb you could you could
you could maximize your sleep
and then wake up and diffuse the bomb
right before it goes off
thereby getting the most rest possible i
think that's great so you have a good
day
i think that's too complex i think it's
more like there
is a child that has fallen
into the you know the place where the
trains come
in the subway okay you're taking a nap
and as the child is following
falling you wake up right before he hits
the ass no no no catch him
again i wake up right before the train
comes i let the child be down there
i mean maybe seven child hit the ground
he probably died no no
no no he landed on his feet and then he
rolled over and now everyone's panicking
they're trying to like should we pull
him up and
i have a little i'm sleeping seven to
eight minutes and then i'm like
train's coming and then i wake up and
then i see that a child
i didn't know about the child i see the
child because i've woken up because the
train is coming
then because i got long arms okay i get
it i pull up so you're really
yeah that's the superhero that i'm gonna
you're a participator
and what that means is that you're a
superhero with no real powers except
that you can maximize your sleep before
doing something
that you need to do matter of fact
you're kind of like a normal person that
wakes up with an alarm
i think you're seeing the wrong end of
this because what i'm saying has nothing
to do with the sleep
the sleep is only the way that the
anticipator begins to anticipate so you
put the anticipator
in a situation where something could be
on schedule a certain schedule
like put the anticipator in there put
him to sleep he'll wake up
right before this thing happens but the
reason why he's so not to defuse the
bomb
but right before the bomb goes off so
probably too late
but at least we'll know it's going to
happen well you could take that into
account you can anticipate the amount of
time it takes to defuse the bomb if
you're the anticipator i don't think i
could get that sophisticated yeah then
you suck
but you're going to be well rested and i
think that that counts for
something yeah
it's interesting because it was just
last week we were talking about the
strange habits of successful people and
one of the things we didn't talk about
was
there's a number of people that wake up
without an alarm clock
oprah there's only one i remember
oprah i mean you could stop right the
list could stop there and it would be
a ringing endorsement i think after a
while no
there's no ringing that's the point
you could silent endorsement i feel like
of waking up without an alarm clock
so you can do that i can do that now and
that is a that is a i can't sleep past 7
30. and here's another thing by the way
but i can't say five o'clock don't need
it is that what she does she sets a time
and then just wakes up for it i think i
know
why this is happening with you
because you have inadvertently set up a
system to train yourself to do this
you don't have a clock that's easily
visible
from your bed you have to wake up more
than you need to
in order to see what time it is to see
if you need to get up
uh for me i have a i have a clock
visible
there that it it i don't use it as the
alarm i use my phone as the wake up
alarm and stuff like that
but i can just easily roll over just
like kind of
like a quarter of the way open one eye
and see what time it is and then just
then just immediately go back to sleep
that's also why you you're not able to
sleep later
on the weekends or something you just
need to be able to roll over give a
little crack to the eye
oh i've got i got 20 minutes i got an
hour the reason i can't sleep late is
because
this is a sore subject between me and my
wife uh
our bedroom doesn't have blocking blinds
because whoever we bought the house from
oh installed you know translucent blinds
you can change that
well yeah of course this i've been
talking about you've been in this house
for going on six years
and um what i told my i tell my wife
i'm like you know when we were on tour
and i would be like in a hotel with
those cra
you know there's like vinyl curtains
that like completely block out
everything yeah and we'd be on a weird
schedule and we
we'd we'd be on the bus and i wouldn't
sleep right on the bus and then we would
get there and we would have a show that
night
i'd sleep till like noon i felt like a
teen again because they had those
blocking curtains the reason i can't
sleep
late i believe is because the sunlight
comes in and
i tell jesse i'm late well that's can we
just get blocking blinds and she says
well i'm going to redo the bedroom
and then we'll and i'm going to get she
then she starts telling me all the
things she's going to do on the windows
and she says and they'll and they'll
block son but
i'm not ready i'm not ready to do that
and i'm like well i'm ready to sleep
past 7
30. and then we come to this standstill
and it never goes anywhere not really a
standstill it's just kind of a
clarification of who's in charge well
that's for sure yeah i mean it's not a
stalemate
i think someone has won yeah well yeah
was she yeah she she is one
uh she wins beauty mask man
well yeah it doesn't i can't it's duct
tape it doesn't stay on my face it's
uncomfortable
i mean come on man i'm trying to help
you and then do you still wear a beauty
mask
uh look at this face do i need a beauty
mask
but you but no no no usually when you
commit to something you don't ever
stop doing it until your death in the
distant future i think that will come up
as we go through some of these things
because um
you know i'm going to talk about some of
these things use one of those
and i'll uh i i used it on tour yeah for
some of the same reasons you're talking
about
uh just blocking out light especially i
started using it on a plane
when i was a a plane rider and then on
the bus
on tour and stuff like that and uh but
yeah
never at home i feel like i can still
sense the sun like on my skin
never at home let's get to let's get to
one of these huh
ash responded to our prompt um
ash says a wrist watch
i always just use my phone and would get
lost in the notifications easily and
sometimes even forget to check the time
it can be used for time management
meaning just the wrist watch
workouts when someone asks
for the time and even as an accessory oh
for fashion changes the game for real
ear biscuits think it's ash for for the
throwback answer right off the bat here
is this is this a smart watch or is this
just a wrist watch
yeah what ash is saying is it's just a
wristwatch
it's it's an anti it's a dumb watch how
do you use that for a workout
uh i don't yeah that's a i guess
i get timing over timing timing and
workout intervals
you know tabata training never heard
that word 20 seconds on 10 seconds off
tabata it's just like high intensity
interval training okay the word makes me
hungry it should definitely be a food
really yeah oh have you had the tabata
burger from tabatas
no it's kind of like a i don't know it's
not a burger it's more like a
it's like a taco and a tostada kind of
it's like a half folded taco okay but we
are talking about a regular wristwatch
which um i don't know man
i i res i respect this the
simplification
of life i mean we both have smart
watches on you know
yours you're loose you're repping the
dink you just went like i'm prepping
i don't do that again i'm repping these
why is it so little
garmin because when i get out of the
shower
i like to uh of course blow dry my
entire body
and that includes under my watch because
i don't i don't like having moist
areas you're not getting good data man
that's so
loose you're not getting good body data
your biometrics are going to be way off
when i'm doing a workout oh but then you
go you go
then i tighten it up but i don't like it
too
like daily biometrics man yeah i know i
know but there's a vein
you know there's a vein right there and
i don't like you think you're going to
cut the vein off
no yeah i feel like i'm crimping the
vein and i'm like
my kids know that i'm like so vein
sensitive
i if sometimes i'll just be sitting
somewhere and
or just a random kid will just come up
and like that vein right there
a random kid well one of my three it's
like one once you have three
i thought you were you're interested in
again you interact
when you have three kids and you
interact with them it starts to feel
like
you're just randomly interacting with
children and they touch it
just to screw with me yeah they'll like
and
and you know like back there on when
you're when your forearms up
and like the back the back of that
forearm there's that one really big vein
oh gosh i'm sorry if i'm freaking out
other people too but hey i'm with you
because they will touch that vein oh
just the screw with it and so you think
the watch
is constricting the vein it's crimping
my veins man
i just think you're you're you're
potentially compromising the function of
the watch but we have smart watches now
this is a i'm intrigued by this question
because just recently
i didn't tell you about i didn't i
didn't tell you about this you don't
have to tell me
i also didn't show you this but but i do
expect it
um in fact yesterday okay
come clean yesterday when i
left my house okay
my shirt was tucked in oh you
okay okay all right i see where this is
going okay
uh again i feel like i am in a i'm in a
weird
phase of my life right now yeah you know
what it's okay right
and uh yeah you know it's very okay i
feel being in a weird fight
okay what you're about to tell me i
don't know if it's okay well i'm gonna
i'm gonna get back to wristwatch just
just go with me here
um i feel like i'm hitting this part of
my life where i
understand that i am
i'm accepting some things by myself one
of the things i'm accepting is that i'm
a 43 year old man
right and
and i and i'm so there's little there's
things happening like we talked
last time we talked about trying to
embrace like i'm going to dress in a
certain way and i'm not going to try to
be
in style or whatever there's other
things that are coming along with that
and one of the things just yesterday now
first of all you know i wear a belt and
we're going to get to that
later as well but i uh stay tuned if
you're a belt person
well somebody suggested that i uh i
i had a shirt that's a little bit too
short but i liked it
and i was like what if i just what if i
just tucked
what if i just tucked this shirt in and
i tucked the shirt in and i walked out
and of course showed my wife who
immediately starts laughing
but i because she knows that i'm coming
to ask her what she thinks about the
tucked in shirt i don't tuck my shirt in
because as we've established we know who
has the power
and she said i was like well what do you
think she was like
do what you want to do huh
and i was like but do you like it and
she said
no she said there's no way no
she said i think it looks i think it
looks good
was it uh it was the sh you uh
you saw me yesterday it was the um is it
button up
it was the button up it's like it was a
button up from that sponsor
that we had that i'm not gonna mention
because they're not sponsoring this
episode
oh uh i love the shirt i love the way it
feels i just wish it was about an inch
longer
and uh so i tucked it in so the shirt's
the problem and then i
came in and i
uh i had to take a leak and i was like
okay as a man who has his shirt tucked
in not as a man who tucks his shirt in
this is a man who doesn't tuck his shirt
in who is currently has his shirt tucked
in
who's thinking about transitioning to
become the man who tucks his shirt in
because why not i mean maybe that's what
i'm going to become is the guy who has
his shirt tucked no i'll answer that
question but i'll just
i'll give you your moment um and then i
was like well
you know how like you know how like when
you when we go
i'd be on a talk show and we wear a suit
yeah i know when we'd be on a talk show
and you gotta
take a piss right before you go on piss
it's a little harsh and you uh
for the tone of this conversation take a
tinkle good uh
when you and you don't want to untuck
your shirt because you've got it all the
way that you want
so you do that you use the zipper and
the as the zipper is intended
[Laughter]
that first of all let me just say that
whole process it's a farce man that
whole process of getting your
tallywhacker
out of your underwear and out of your
zipper
right and then i've seen childbirth
easier than that
and then fully getting it feeling like
you've got it all out
i don't know i just feel like i gotta
reach under there and kind of talk about
crimping the veins
i feel like you know i feel like i got a
i feel what i'm saying yeah yeah i feel
like i got to hit the evac button
you know the evac button you know where
it is and you feel like you got to hit
it just to make
how are you sure and this is not an old
man thing i've been doing this since i
was a
toddler the taint the the taint
you got to hit the taint you got to
press the taint make sure that it's on
that button yeah and uh evac button
that's what i'm calling it
and uh you can't get to
you can't get to the table anyone who
doesn't know about this
what some people who don't know about it
are picturing right now is some you
you're you're reaching down there and
like you're pressing a
button and all of a sudden there's like
a gut well there's sometimes there's
something and sometimes there's not
that's why that's why you do it it's a
it's a safety it's a backup
yeah it's a and it and it's especially
important when you've got the
tallywhacker out of the pants and you're
about to go on national television
and you don't want to have a p spot so
because sometimes as you're pulling it
back in
yeah you know what i'm saying if you
haven't hit the evac button it might
decide to evac
on its own if the right if the
sea snake's going back in the coral you
know he's gonna leave a little
he's gonna leave a little do they spray
ink i don't know whatever
so i'm in the bathroom and i've got it
out
great and then i'm like what the hell am
i doing
yes right right yeah and so i put it
back in and i
unzip okay oh and i hit the evac button
hold on unzip you had already unzipped
it was out
i undid my belt and took everything oh
okay okay
you unbuttoned it underneath i couldn't
get to it and then
but you didn't put it back in first
um there's no need to do that now put it
back in my underwear
because i had to put then pull my
underwear down
oh god i forgot about that this is so
graphic
i mean i'm thinking a graphic i kind of
need a diagram so that make sure people
follow them i'll put pictures on my
instagram uh no i won't
okay so uh anyway
after i took it out and i mean by that i
mean my shirt tale
uh i'm like i'm what am i doing i i
worry about this another day
and then i just left it out and i came
in here and forgot all about it
but earlier that day when i was tucked
i was i i went and looked at myself in
the full-length mirror that we have in
our bathroom
and i was like you know i've got these i
got these boots and i've got these
jeans and i got my buttoned up tucked in
and i've got this belt
you got this beard you got that face and
then i looked at
my apple watch my smartwatch and i was
like
that doesn't fit that doesn't fit this
persona
like if i'm building a sims character
this guy wouldn't have an apple watch he
would have like a
real wrist watch he would have an analog
wall talking about what i've got
no manly watch no that's that's a
digital watch
it looks like it looks like a diver's
watch i'm not i'm saying
i'm talking about like a metal like a
metal watch that's shiny and has like a
leather band or a metal band or
something like that
a fancy fancy watch and so then i was
like do i need that to complete this
look and then i just want to buy a watch
to justify tucking in your shirt
you are you really are upended man uh
take it you need a you need to retreat
no i just think that there's a
transition happening
a transition happening and i feel like
if you tuck
the shirt in i at least got to go back
to i have a leather band for this watch
that i wear
i got to put the leather band back on
the apple watch don't go down this road
i think i this this is the road of oh
becoming an old man i'm on you're on the
road too you
constantly denying it um i'm not
on that road but i am on that road and i
am embracing it i'm
i'm going to i'm embracing what is going
to unfold over the next decade
and what is going to fold apparently my
t-shirt into my
pants and maybe my wiener into my zipper
um
[Music]
i'm just saying i i just feel like
that's what
this made me think about is that maybe i
need to watch not because i need to do
all the stuff that ash is talking about
but because i need to complete the look
everything you've said yeah is important
to yeah it to the decision that is
obvious that you need to make
you you've you've you've made every
argument
as to why you should not be tucking your
shirts in
why did what how did how is that where
you land you know what
uh listen to ear biscuits this episode
wherever podcasts are found
and the past 10 minutes just re listen
back to it and it will all become clear
to you
you should not be talking about you're
talking my shirt but i want to go back
forget where we thought we were going
for the time being i'm going to tuck it
in
i want to go back to the to the peeing
thing because
listen man i feel like we could help we
always talk about this at the beginning
of your biscuits going through why does
this happen
going like trying to
like exit get get your wiener to come
out of the underwear through that thing
and then go through the
like to go through this gauntlet in
order to pee is it it kinks things up
it's not a
it doesn't it creates problems and even
if you're going to push that button
like i mean i've i've tried some i've
tried some things over the years and
boy you think you're done you think you
know you think you pressed a button and
stuff like that and then you put it back
in your pants i full on
peed in my pants thinking that i was
done
like and i'm talking like it within the
past
month it happened and i but i wasn't
even tucking my shirt in hold on
you're saying that you did your normal
technique and you still whizzed on
yourself
i can't remember that what's your thing
is that what you're saying yeah i can't
remember what happened
but i definitely can't just like it
you think it works that way but it
doesn't because
you just there's two there's too many
kinks in the hose
it's just not it's not especially with
the tighter pants
the tighter pants is a problem and
that's the real problem with this with
the suits that we wear that are just way
too tight but that's what they say we
should be wearing i don't want to get
more graphic but i'm going to because i
think that it
you need to i think that well listen i'm
not i'm not embarrassed
and i don't but you talk about pushing
the button
yeah i mean i am so afraid of peeing in
my own pants
or dribbling or like being seen with
like the dribbles
on that like coming through the the
pants
that sometimes you have to go all the
way to just milk the snake
oh gosh i mean i've you ever seen
somebody milk a real snake
like milk the venom out of a snake yeah
that's different they like put the fangs
over the edge of a cup
i'm not talking i don't do anything with
my wiener that looks like that
well you uh i do
i mean not the i don't like i
i don't like putting on that i don't put
it on the edge of the toilet seat
and then bring a foot up like stomp
take the just take the other part of the
seat and bring it down
get on your knees like dad what are you
doing don't touch my vein
yeah it's like you better make sure the
door is locked if you're gonna eat
take a knee and use the seat to smush
out any uh
yeah i don't i don't know i don't have
to do that oh man
usually it's just a quick press of the
button but
i mean there's a lot of and if you don't
know about this button the the button i
don't think
it you don't think everybody has the
button the button isn't foolproof
to me it's like if you got a the button
is just
a picture if there were buttons along
all along the exit route
and you're pushing multiple buttons yeah
well that that is the foolproof way
that's
that's i i mean out of compulsion
i do that i'll do that if i'm wearing
like gray sweats
right if i'm wearing something that's
like you can't
if i can't afford a drop okay here's
what i'll do here's what i'll milk this
thing
if i'm wearing gray sweats at someone
else's house
you know what i'm saying i gotta come
back
those two things usually don't happen i
don't want to be in my own house
great sweats at somebody else's house uh
you know i haven't been to somebody i
was at your house uh recently uh
but i was wearing uh you were in the
bathroom a long time well i was taking a
dump
i took a dump in your in your in your
bathroom the other night
sorry i mean i thought that was what it
was for
um not ideally for you no
i mean i don't come over your house
thinking i'm definitely going to take a
dump but you're
christie's done a really good job with
that guest bathroom it's a nice bathroom
i like being in there
yeah if somebody's done a really good
job of designing a bathroom and as a
matter of fact
everybody on the wall yes in your
bathroom is what you have on your shirt
that's right
is it the same artist i don't know um
i think it's either whoever made the
wallpaper is ripping off the artist who
made your shirt or it's the same artist
i like feeling like there's an audience
of a bunch of people watching you
watching me take a dump
no i didn't have to melt the snake
because i had on black jeans yeah you
got to think about that and that's why i
can wear my underwear
how does this become more days than if
you're still listening
i'm sorry i got a lot of backlash for
confessing that like i don't
some i you know i wear the same pair of
underwear
i don't know what i said but now i'm
just gonna say two days in a row
and you know what since i confessed that
and people just gave me [ __ ]
about it i don't do that anymore but
that's because i didn't want to talk
about
well listen you could do what you want i
have a bidet and i milk the snake
so there's nothing happening inside of
my underwear
except a little bit of sweat and i don't
even that's not where i sweat so
it's i'm fine y'all i'm fine okay
don't don't judge me all right uh
go to mythical.com no one has judged
anybody i'm sure
uh we're half an hour into this podcast
and uh
we've only gotten through one question
and we didn't even really address it um
i was in the ad go to mythical.com okay
buy
merch um we are introducing merch
all the time which means
that it goes away
and we're just continuing all the time
it's about to go away you might want to
know about it because you if you're
eyeing something you want to get it
before it's gone
we have a section for that called
last chance last chance
section last chance the wrapper
last chance section because we don't
bring things back
usually usually sometimes sometimes we
do but most of the time we don't so if
you want to get it go to the last
chance section at mythical.com all right
okay oh you're still with us
wow wow that was quite a test
there's a number of people who stopped
listening to this one or at least
fast-forwarded at this point welcome
mari said audiobooks is something i
can't live without i didn't think i'd
retain the
book as much compared to reading it
myself
but i tried it out with rhett's wreck of
the stranger in the woods
and i must say it's been nice lounging
on the sofa
having a book read to me kind of feel
like royalty
i think read to me
it's spelled the same way well no i'm
thinking that the book is reading to you
well i mean i guess it's a person
technically having someone
i think they intended to read but okay
having a book
read to me but the unless you think the
book itself is reading either way
all right i'm feeling this mari i mean i
i too have gotten more into audio books
having listened to you talk about
listening to books
it's like yeah i should be doing that
like so i go through like the podcast
phase and then i'll go back to the book
phase and
um i got too many credits
on my you know my audible account so i i
was
i was looking into pausing it which you
have to email customer service to pause
it and you can pause it for three months
just gotta get more books man how many
credits do you have eight
i just don't i don't i only listen to it
going i only listen to books
when i'm walking sometimes in the car
yeah i
i'm uh i don't i don't i mean i've never
i've never laid down and just had a book
read to
me no i don't do that
uh sounds like fun though audiobooks man
i
i feel like it has revolutionized
the book industry because there has to
be
just there's so many books already but
i'm reading and i and i use the term
reading
to say listen i i don't like to say
i don't like to qualify i found myself
for over the past year or two
i would always qualify i read that well
i listened to it on all right
yeah as if it was lesser i don't believe
that it's lesser i mean
the history the most of the history of
our species
was pre-written it was oral
it was you you got your stories via
an oral storyteller right it's just a
very recent
concept the idea that we would you have
to justify
that you're actually getting information
because it's been translated into
words screw that but i mean written
words you are currently justifying it
i'm definitely justifying it
but i'm saying i don't qualify you're
saying that you don't need to
uh exactly so live and live in jesse's
power
um do you think my wife is uh i'm just
trying to make that a runner
for the episode that she's powerful oh
she's very powerful
and but in contrast to you
i have no problem with admitting that
right
or living on that living so just listen
to the books and um
but here's what i'll say you've
empowered many you
me mari i'm lit i'm listening
i this morning listen to a book while i
worked out listen and
listen i only listen to books while
driving
i got i kind of feel like i've made a
choice i really like music but i
only listen to music while i'm writing
while i'm working
i don't listen to music any other time
now and
it's i have to split my time that that's
the thing for me with audiobooks is that
i love listening to music
so much that i kind of have to make a
disciplined decision to
to continue to like get into my book
but like so that's why walking my walks
has become my
my book zone and i and there's not a
temptation to listen to music
so and now when i'm mountain biking by
myself
i'll also i can listen to uh an audio
book sometimes
well um speaking usually on the uphill
and then on the downhill part i might
switch to music
though that's interesting because
speaking of my
powerful wife um
she comes down and i i like to work out
by myself
okay let's just i'll just be honest and
she knows this but you know there's only
so much time in the day for both of us
so sometimes we're both down there
now what i do when i'm working out is i
listen to
an audiobook and sometimes i listen to
like a very dry
like academic audiobook about some
scientific concept or something like
that while i'm like sitting there going
and she comes down there and just laughs
at me she's like how do you do this
how do you work out hard yeah and listen
to this
professor talk about this thing yeah
it's a juxtaposition
she's like i gotta have music and so she
comes down of course she's the powerful
one so we listen to music
and when we're listening to music i feel
like i'm missing out on something i'm
like
man i had an hour here and i was
learning and if she wasn't here
i would be making my body better and
also making my mind better but now i'm
just listening to
drivel i'm listening to alicia keys say
this girl is on fire
is he doing that yeah it which by the
way
is an excellent song to work out to i
understand
yeah it's got that it's got a big beat
and then there's that
i mean jesse has put together this
playlist and it's it's got some
you know it's not current it's got like
that gwen when you know when gwen
stefani like hit that stride
and was like um um
what's i don't know when it was it was
like 10 years ago
on that song with eve where it's like is
that
but then i'm just like man i can't wait
to get my car to learn something
you're addicted to ideas uh yeah
definitely
think about it
think about it you're gonna get yourself
into trouble so
what are we talking about audiobooks uh
i couldn't i can't live without them
couldn't live i mean of course i could
live without them but
i see them as a necessary part of my
life at this point uh
rachel said pop socket
i thought they were so dumb until i got
one and i can't hold my phone without it
helps when i'm fidgety but i don't
switch out the designs
which you could do um you pop socketed
for a while
i did and um my my phone
case broke and i haven't gotten a new
one because i thought i was going to get
a new phone
so instead of getting a new case i just
waited until i got a new phone but then
i never got a new phone so now i have a
caseless phone
and it's it's slicker because there's no
case i don't know how you live like that
and i was thinking about instead of
getting a case just getting a pop socket
hey we sell those mythical.com you got
you can get a mythical pop socket
um you might think it's stupid until you
try it out
i gotta go back to it because i've
noticed that here's the thing i hold the
phone like this
and so my pinky is below the phone
and and it turns out there is
you know you think you hold it in random
places but
it goes to the exact same place i hold
my phone in the exact same way
right on the vein and then yeah i pinch
the vein and
that now i'm getting a pain right here
on my pinky finger
this isn't funny i mean literally it
hurts like
when i go to like my instinctive
location to look at my phone
my pinky finger there's a paint spot
well and i need a pop socket no
look rubber so you get a k i do the same
thing but mine doesn't hurt because i
got a little rubber protective little
thing and you know what
i think that's what it is it didn't hurt
until my my case has been gone long
enough
i mean you don't need a pop socket you
need a tunnel
uh we don't sell cases listen we maybe
we should
we we sell pop sockets but let me just
say this is truth in advertising
i don't use them and i don't i don't
i don't that's not what truth and
advertising is when you when you say you
sell something but you don't
know it is truth in advertising okay
you're being truthful about something
that we advertise
yeah that you don't use i'm saying i
want you to have the opportunity to buy
a mythical pop socket if you're into
that but i don't
endorse them personally or use them
i just think that what happens with me
with the pop socket
is it makes it it gets caught on
yeah i just want to get this thing in
and out of my pocket
as quickly as possible but i wanted to
have a little resistance
uh i can't imagine there's been a couple
of days when i've gone without a case i
mean i have a i have a case and
a screen protector a glass why don't
they just make
phones with this with the
case as part of it well because then you
wouldn't have the power of choice
and then also they wouldn't be able to
brag about how thin it is make a phone
good enough that you don't need a case
well i mean that's how you know neil
degrasse tyson
famously doesn't have a phone case
and when asked about it he will take his
phone and play around with it
and show that he's like i'm not going to
drop this why would i need a case the
only reason i would need a case
is if i needed the phone to be protected
from me
and i don't need to protect my phone
from me but i i'm not neil degrasse
tyson
i may be addicted to ideas but i'm not
neil degrasse tyson
and i need a case because i do need to
protect my phone for myself but i don't
need a pop socket but if you need one
more power to you jafar says
a memory foam pillow i'm a tall fellow
who has tremendous back and neck
issues and switching to this pillow
brought the pain i deal with in the
mornings to an almost tolerable level
i have so much trouble sleeping without
it
um the way you sleep is key to you know
dealing with chronic pain but it can't
be the extent of but jafar i'm gonna i'm
gonna point you to
uh rhett's video where he he shows you
his stretching routine
he hasn't made it yet but uh we're
really laying on the
pressure now it's like here's what i'll
say you know this is you can go
it's needed i just went on the internet
and put together a bunch of exercises
it's not like i'm some stretching guru i
do plan on making a video about it but
like you can also
just put together what feels good to you
now i had neck pain
when i went to my uh physical therapist
who you know told me i needed to invite
my party
i believe i also told you at the time
that she sold me
a flaxseed filled cylindrical
pillow that um put it up on amazon this
thing is called
sachi organics buckwheat oh so it's not
flaxseed it's buckwheat yeah flax seeds
like what you eat cylinder neck pillow i
think some of them do have flaxseed in
them
and um i'm still using that thing almost
a year later but
that's the only pillow that you use yeah
there's nothing else nothing else
but uh i kind of hate it do you sleep on
your back or you think it works it
forces me to sleep
on my back and it
it arches my could you sleep on your
side pushes my chin
down into my neck
and it kind of so it stretches out the
back of my neck
in such a way that it doesn't hurt when
you wake up um there's like
it kind of puts it in traction in a good
way
oh yeah suppose i mean the reviews are
are really positive on amazon
uh 670 reviews four and a half stars
i mean it cost like 37 bucks
but i'll tell you it was it took it took
weeks of just saying you know what i'm
committed to this thing
and even now like almost a year later
whenever i roll on my side it's
really not that comfortable so i kind of
wake up i wake up enough to
to correct and go back to my back but um
that's kind of part of it
uh i guess this memory foam pillow the
way that this one is shaped for jafar
kind of helps i'm seeing a new one being
pushed on instagram right now that has a
hole
it's a memory foam pillow with a hole in
the middle basically
that simulates the same posture that my
seed pillow is also the square pillow
well that one also has
if you sleep on your side sleeper it has
two it's too small it has a big hole in
the middle
and two smaller holes on the side so if
you roll on your side
your ear is like suspended in a
crater i'm like okay this sounds like a
gimmick
it feels a little overwhelming my
buckwheat
pillow yeah what you know i told you
about the i do think it's helped
the uh the contraption that i bought
that was designed to keep you sleeping
on your back that had like
it was a belt that you wore right had
these big plastic
balls and so if you slept on your side
you would be sleeping on top of a ball
and you'd wake up i tried it for about a
week
and i just
i'm a side sleeper and i wa i want to be
a back sleeper i do
i think it's supposed to be it's the
best for a number of different reasons
but
i don't know i'm not having trouble with
my back or my neck
because of sleeping so i'm kind of just
on my side but here's my result now
i want to get your take on this because
my resistance
my resistance to
a particular pillow now i have two
pillows they're both
down pillows but one of them is one of
them is two
is two like your head goes all the way
to the ground that doesn't work
and the other one maybe it's not down
it's like synthetic down and so it's
actually got some
support so it feels good that way you
don't hear the echoes
of the screaming geese in your ears my
resistance
to pillows
specialty pillows is a fear of becoming
reliant upon them yeah i was about to
say i think i would
i will tr i travel with my um
buckwheat pillow it's small enough
it's like a quarter the size
of like a normal pillow it's just big
enough to go underneath my neck
and like come across my shoulders a
little bit yeah you can take it with you
yeah but that's that's why i've resisted
and i'm not currently hurting but
i'm glad i'm glad uh jafar has found a
pillow
some something else that um i was trying
to think
how would i answer this question i got a
couple of things
um a pill box
i've finally gotten a day of the week
pillbox
so you're not embracing your old age oh
mr pillbox oh we talk about him raising
your old age yeah i know christy told
you this the other day
we were sitting down for a special
pillow and you have a pill box i mean
you should just come along and start
tucking with me
we were sitting down for dinner the
other night and uh
christy said you are such an old man
what are you drinking
it's it's it's 7 p.m we're eating dinner
and i'm like coffee i was drinking a
i i mean it was it was a saturday i like
to stay up late so i drink
i'll drink a i'll drink my afternoon
coffee later in the day i realized i'd
forgotten about it but here i was
at the dinner table eating dinner and
drinking hot
coffee and that's such an old man thing
to do
but you know what i can't live without
my pill box because that's
it's i don't know there's something
rewarding
about i mean it's so efficient like it
makes me happy to know that like i can
efficiently just dump
open the open the thursday container pop
them all into my mouth
and swallow away what are you taking
it's the stuff that christy gave me
you know where the power lies yeah but
do you know what it is she could be
poisoning you
um she could be but i think that's
that's part of the i'm how many are the
trust how many things are we talking
about
um there's two huge black pills horse
pills that are like um
tranquilizers it's so it's something
that you and her both
over the course of the pandemic have
like said i needed to have but i don't
know it's a black pill
and then i've got the wellness pill that
is like a multivitamin
you you legitimately do not know what it
is it's just like my wife told me to
take it i drink my coffee i know there's
put it in my
melatonin is one of them but i think
that one's really small there's a fish
oil one that i don't need to be taking
melatonin every day
i'll let you vet my pills later
it's just it's a small pill well it
doesn't matter how small it is
you don't need to be taking melatonin
just tell me the days i need to take it
and i can put it in that corresponding
bin
i'll send you and i could be wrong about
all this
that's what that's what scares me i'll
talk to your wife about it again it's
like i
i trust her i'm not addicted to that
idea of knowing
what's in my pill box you know like an
old man should
when i put the pills in the box all i do
is i take this yeah for the
corresponding day and i just swallow all
the people you're you're a person your
case that you're not embracing your old
age
is diminishing quickly falling apart
i like the feeling of the efficiency of
it and it also helps me know what day it
is
well that's important yeah they
certainly run together that's important
um i have too many i i have too many
pills
in fact i was recently searching for
like how could i get
a pill box that could you need but hold
all of the things that i take a series
of connected buckets like bozo the
clowns
uh ping pong toss game and i and i did i
i don't remember
when it was it was last year or year or
two ago
posted a picture of all the things that
i was taking on my vacation i was like
seven i don't know two week vacation
here's what i'm taking
and of course that's when the internet
experts come out and they're like
there's no reason to be taking all of
that stuff
oh yeah you just pee it all out and
right okay maybe
yeah as we we can talk you want to talk
about pee again is that what you're i
want to use a pill box
that's justification enough that's what
you should tell them well
i can't every single morning i do
something that would
uh drive you absolutely nuts now that
you've mentioned the pillbox you open
everyone
individually it's almost a ritual at
this point
i have a shelf that has all the things
that i take now when i wake up
i take four things right before my
workout
and then after my workout i take about
five or six things and then
at night before i go to bed i take about
seven or eight things because you're
addicted to ideas
and uh it's i have reasons for every
single thing that i'm taking
and uh but yeah it's almost like okay
you should try having no reasons like me
here's here's here here's this thing
i open it i take it out i take it
and i'm like this is not sustainable but
it's only something that has
worked in quarantine because you got
time to burn
but when we went on our little uh beach
vacation
couple i don't know when it was a month
ago or so
again i don't have a pill box that can
accommodate this so i put
everything into a one ziploc bag and i
was like i'll sort it out when i get
there
and then that was when i discovered that
i've got a number of things that look
similar and i'm like is that the vitamin
d or is that the garlic
um well i need both of them so
anyway i i i just if you if you know of
a big pill box
that can accommodate about 20
supplements and then has it divided up
by day
uh that doesn't look like a tackle box
because i
i'm thinking about getting a tackle box
because i feel like that might be the
only thing that will hold it
oh man i remember i had a tackle box as
a kid and i would store my gi joe men in
there i totally forgotten about that
like all those little boxes all those
little compartments it's so
fun well maybe i'll get you a tackle box
for your birthday i love
i love it i love the feeling of opening
up
something and then the way that tackle
boxes work is that you
you open the top shell case and then
it it has the the tiered
layers there's stadium seating in there
yeah it just kind of splays out before
you man
yeah man it's amazing okay well maybe
tackle box is
what we're talking about a product that
i thought was stupid
until i found that we had one we
purchased one
and now i love it i'm looking for i'm
looking for excuses to use it
a dust buster i remember when those
originals
hit the scene in the 80s nana and papa
had one at their house
and i was like wow it you know it it's
rechargeable
it's a it's a vacuum cleaner in the palm
of your hand
it's just so much better than like
a broom what are you cleaning up with it
um i think they bought it
for for like kitty litter that like
strolls out on the ground around the
kitty litter box i think that's why
it it i think it appeared around the
same time as saka
at the house but now it's recharging in
the garage because apparently
they didn't want to keep it in a room so
like i'm just looking for like
little corners of the garage
like i'm like oh there's i could get now
i can get all the dust out of this
corner of the garage
you know it's here i'm here have a
little bonding moment
you know it's just you know it's not an
old man just things that bring us not at
all bring
joy into your dusting into the corners
just dust buzzing the corners of his
tackle box
um samantha really
brought something that i have become
completely dependent upon a white noise
machine
my daughter is two and has been using it
since she left the womb
and now i can't even i can
even i can't sleep without one um
i've talked about my white noise machine
yeah
which is not it it's electronic but it's
supposed to like
resemble the sound of a fan and it's
very loud and i have it
on every single night for a number of
reasons
one my wife she's so powerful and when
you're that powerful
sometimes it leads to snoring oh yeah um
you know because you're just trying to
contain it
and uh and then also you know if my kids
are having emergencies or whatever i
want them to deal with that on their own
so
um i i have this thing and then when i
travel
i have to get my phone i have the white
noise app on my phone but i again i have
some shame around this
because i have become i mean i haven't
tried to sleep without it but i mean
even when i went on my solo trip
and i'm out in the middle of nowhere i'm
like i need my little
and so i'd use my i'd use my phone my
phone would be like dead in the morning
um i don't know and but i i like to
think about things in terms of
how functional they would be as i as i
have said
for years when the war comes you know uh
when when world war three happens and
we're all you know basically when the
apocalypse happens
and i'm sort of like my family and i are
walking across a
desert landscape and you know when i
become meat again
and let me just interject that we've
established that you have
already mastered as the anticipator the
art of waking up with an alarm clock yet
you're very concerned that you're not
able to go to sleep
without the constant noise of an app
playing so it's like i i don't know well
here's the thing
as a desk and a molehill here as a
despotic
uh apocalyptic ruler who keeps people on
leashes
uh you know which is the the role i
want to assume in the apocalypse some
sort of overlord
um i can't be the guy i can't have like
a necklace made out of human baby bones
around my neck and then need a white
noise machine to go to sleep that's bad
for the image
no i'll tell you i'll tell you the
what's gonna save this for you
media games going to be like hey
jonathan get in here you're going to
stay up all night
making noise and you're going to in my
ear there's no way that
that that won't work you just got a guy
gargling
that would be very annoying and you're
tense it is the
perfect pitch binaural you could have
jonathan and taylor one on each ear
jonathan and taylor and then thomas is
down there massaging your feet
okay well i'll get people to do my white
noise for me
yeah but i i feel i i feel
self-conscious about the fact that i
need it
but i'm such a light sleeper man i wake
up it i wake up
so easily most desperate to get fed
grapes
grapes won't be a thing in the
apocalypse i don't think they can
actually i don't think that agriculture
can be sustained
should the team should be enjoying enjoy
the grapes despo
death ball i don't know i don't think so
is it french do you mean like
depot yeah silent and depot
but not despot should it be though
just in our little corner of the
internet can we make the t silent in
despot
sure i mean do what you want to despa
despo
um do you want to talk about another one
or do you just want to give you a wreck
oh you ready for my wreck already i mean
i wait you know what look listen
it's been a good episode let's go out on
a high note okay
sure let's not push it okay i think you
know what i feel like the energy's been
really good this episode you don't want
to ruin it i don't want to ruin it
you feel like it's hanging in the
balance we covered a lot of ground yep
we've
we we've dangled out the zipper and and
now it's it's all about
we spent a lot of time talking it's all
about i'm sorry pulling it back in
in a way to not do damage to anybody's
pants oh just because i said it i just
want to give credit to the person who
said
it uh fisher we have so many more
this is such a good prompt we'll do it
again i just want i just wanna you wanna
do it again
i just wanna you wanna do a sequel to
this episode no not a sequel like
let's just keep going what i just wanna
give credit cause i said i would to
bonsai breath
fisher who says a belt i grew up wearing
belts because i had to never thought
anything of it
continued to wear belts every day only
when my favorite belt broke
and i was beltless did i realize how
much i need it
uh if i can name two things that i need
it's the white noise machine and a belt
because i mean of course if i'm wearing
like those gray sweats and at somebody's
house and i'm coming out
you know with a p spot i don't need
belts for sweatpants but for jeans i
gotta have a belt
pants just work their way down things
get exposed if i don't have a belt
yeah i'm i must not be shaped the same
it's a different it's a it's a body
shape thing
yeah i don't you don't need a belt i
don't
uh does that make me better than you
maybe
uh well that's that's that's up to you
okay then it does yeah okay
um but i uh
i don't feel it feels like there's a
part of me
missing if there's not a slight cinch
there's a slight cinch in the midsection
area can i have that cinch
so you like like pinching into a vent
you like to pinch the veins it doesn't
pinch
it's just a cinch there's a difference
between a pinch and a cinch
and you really need to know that if
you're thinking about a belt as a pinch
then of course you're not going to wear
one let's give a shout out to the people
that
submitted some good stuff that we're not
we're not just
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna acknowledge their
contribution but we're not gonna do this
this is
never done so you're basically saying
we're just throwing these to the wayside
oh no we're not you think we're gonna do
this again
we never do things again well that's not
true but okay go ahead
we can always get more chloe said a
plug-in
mug warmer i drink my coffee very slowly
and this thing keeps it warm forever
it doesn't provide any links to anything
but it looks like a
just a a white almost looks like a
wireless charger
that her um in this case good mythical
morning mug i love that
says oh 15 on amazon didn't put the link
though
fisher said about klaus at a squatty
potty
neppy nut said uh
a quality set of kitchen knives having a
good set of knives
up my cooking game dramatically and i
still have no idea
how i ever imagined ever managed without
them
very important um yeah
i mean we can still talk about this
again but i'll give a wreck
you ready for a wreck baby wreck baby
one two three far
um i don't know what it is about
amazon's television shows but i think
once i beca and i'm not loyal to
them as a streaming platform but i start
watching things on hbo and it does lead
to seeing the other things that i want
to check out
um so i started watching
um what's it called uh
painting with john which debuted
uh like i said on hbo back in january
um and you said amazon series did i say
amazon
yeah why did i say hbo you said amazon
because i think we were just talking
about amazon links to uh
hbo yeah painting with john is just a
totally
laid-back uh comedic
introspective almost calming
um well it is it's kind of a calming
show that you can just kind of just kind
of chill out too
i what i didn't realize is that john
lurie the
uh writer uh producer
star of of of the show
um he was not only a musician
and a painter this is about him painting
and an actor
but he's um he's the founding member
along with his brother of the
band the lounge lizards which is like
this like
jazz type i've never listened to lounges
yeah i just heard of him but i've heard
of him
and he tells the story of meeting barry
white he tells a lot of stories from his
life and it's like
while he's painting but in an anti-bob
ross way like
he even says in the opening episode he's
like bob ross was wrong
like everybody can't paint you know he
has that yeah right right
he has his like he's got some snark i
don't know if a cervic
is the right descriptor for his uh
uh comedic sensibility but it's it's
like an
anthony bourne danish kind of a tone
yeah uh
but he's also kind of goofy at times
and uh you can tell that this show is
just
kind of his brainchild and it's just
it's just kind of a nice way to
just relax hear a guy telling telling
some stories
it'll get you thinking and um
uh i don't think it's for the children
unless you i think unless you've got an
adult i think it's rated r
but i can't quite remember i just liked
it so i don't think shows are wrong adam
mckay
is an executive producer dang adam mckay
man
he does he does he's he's got a lot of
stuff he does some good
stuff uh he also had a show called
fishing with john i've heard about 15 19
1991
i didn't realize it was the same guy but
people i've never heard one online talk
about fishing with john
huh so painting with john
check it out on hbo if you think you're
feeling you're into that
well thanks for engaging with us
thanks for enduring the half hour
conversation about
finding the uh the special button in
your taint to uh be able to
leak your liz your lounge lizard
[Laughter]
uh you heard it here from the
anticipator
and the the clueless pill taker
oh okay there we go that's a super duo
hashtag gear biscuits we'll talk at you
next week
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right
to watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe if you prefer
to listen to this podcast it's available
on all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best